[Music]
chuck another explainer
yes yeah except we're running out of
stuff that i'm an expert in so we gotta
we gotta reach for other places now okay
yeah i think i'm i'm tapping we're
striking
yeah the whole universe i got the
universe covered but earth that's
another thing
so
what there's such
intriguing disastrous news about
catastrophic flooding
in the world recently and places that
that that are that we've never seen it
before
and i just thought you know is there
someone
nearby and of course columbia university
has has
very rich traditions in thinking about
uh climate not only with the nasa
a branch of nasa that's there the
goddard institute for space studies but
hold departments on this and so we found
a professor where this is what he does
uh radley horton bradley welcome to star
talk
thank you it's great to be here again
you tell me tell me your official title
so i'm a climate scientist at the lamont
dougherty earth observatory located a
little north of colombia's main campus
i'm also part of colombia's emerging
interdisciplinary climate school
which is going to be on the main campus
an exciting new initiative to blend
earth science with impacts and solutions
to these challenges and and your
specialty is what within climate science
climate prediction extreme weather
events extreme weather
and adaptation okay
so you're the main you got the hottest
thing going right that's right chuck
he's the man he's the man other events
yeah so
so so
rally floods are nothing new i mean
there's the flood
legend in gilgamesh in the bible
and
so
so why should anyone think differently
about recent flooding than we've ever
thought about flooding in the past
yeah well you're right i mean flooding
is one of the most fundamental dangers
that the climate system presents us with
but as we're experiencing global warming
temperatures are rising by one or two
degrees which doesn't sound like much
it means that that atmosphere is capable
of holding more moisture
and as a result when conditions are
right
we're seeing much heavier rain events
than we've when conditions are wrong
okay there you go thanks for correcting
me on that wrong statement no i mean
just to give a sense of this um over the
eastern half of the united states just
in the last 50 years or so there's
evidence that that sort of worst
heaviest rain event per year
now
provides about 50 percent more rain than
it did
two generations ago right when we built
a lot of our critical infrastructure
right so the infrastructure that's a
good point because when you when you
create cities you say how big should the
sewer pipe be how high should the flood
wall be how how how uh what's the slope
of the street towards the drain so good
engineers civil engineers calculating
all this and they would have no idea
what future
challenges would that they would
confront with their design
yeah the statistics of these events have
changed in a way that those designers
couldn't foresee back then and what's
really you know distressing about it is
let's just say you increase the rain by
20 percent um
that doesn't mean twenty percent more
flooding it might mean three hundred
percent more flooding right because it's
like you don't flood at all up until a
certain point and then boom things can
get out of control uh in a hurry and put
on top of that a lot of this
infrastructure is aging right it's
beyond its intended lifetime or we
haven't invested enough to to maintain
it so it's a
it's a challenging situation we never
invest enough to maintain or to take
preventative measures but we always have
enough money to pay for the damage which
runs
normally five to ten times more than the
investment
an ounce of prevention right a dollar
towards yeah no that's right okay so
hold the cities aside for the moment
could you tell me what is physically
happening in a flood normally when it
rains the water just goes into the soil
if it rains a little more why doesn't it
go into the soil a little more i don't
see the problem yeah right so maybe just
to back it up even more just to remind
folks the difference between rainfall
and flooding right rainfall stating the
obvious here is what's coming out of the
atmosphere could in theory be snow but
you know most of the time it's rain
not all rain events turn into floods so
what determines whether it's a flood
certainly that's my question yeah yeah
is this sorry
is the rate of the rainfall um but then
we also have to turn to things like what
is the land surface like have we
replaced these soils which might have
been pretty good with strip malls yes
parking lots
um you know that's going to increase
these flood rates dramatically when we
see regions that have experienced
deforestation
or maybe forest fires during drier times
uh eliminating some of this vegetation
that can set the stage when it does rain
again for moisture not getting taken up
by the the soil which gets sort of a
firm surface to the root systems of
trees right exactly yeah these aren't
there to take up that moisture anymore
um so we get more extreme flood events
largely due to these longer lasting rain
events and more intense rainfall per
hour right that because that's sort of
worst
hour worst rate of rain that matters the
most but there's these other components
too how we're changing the landscape and
decisions we make about things like dams
too right also have and water management
also have have implications we've seen
footage the most what i've seen most
recently is flooding in las vegas
where it hardly ever rains there so i
guess there's a difference between heavy
rain where it has rained before and
heavy rain where no one has any clue
what to do about it because all the
roofs were leaking into the interior
because no one
checks if the roof has holes if it never
rains right absolutely there was water
flooding out of the lamp the light
fixtures and the ceiling going on all
the the craft tables and
and the and the the bedding machines and
i just thought to myself wow
this is something
predicted
yeah well you you would have predicted
it you predict
nope maybe i'd like to like to say i
would have i don't know if i would it's
these things are happening so much
faster what happened in pakistan update
me on that
okay so though you know i was looking
into that recently we're over a thousand
deaths now as a result of these rain
events
is pakistan in the in the monsoon zone
or not
pakistan is in the monsoon monsoon is
flooding and they get that every year so
why is this different it does they're
really at the extreme sort of western
edge of the monsoon zone and what that
means is the monsoon on average arrives
later it's a relatively short monsoon
season and it can vary quite a bit year
to year sometimes it doesn't make it all
the way into extreme parts of pakistan
um but this is a so there's high
variability generally there in the month
but it's been really extreme this year
since they started keeping records in
roughly 1961 a little while after
partition this is the worst year in
terms of the amount of right the
partition between india and pakistan
yeah it's actually about a decade later
but you know 1961 i think was was when
the record started um
and you know we're talking about five to
ten times as much rainfall as the
typical year um depending on depending
on where you're where you're looking at
and this is you know to generalize about
the country a lot of mountainous areas
right a lot of dependence on these river
valleys where people are concentrated
into low areas and rivers the
infrastructure is there populations are
there crops are there so when you get
that water being channeled
through these mountain valleys
the people
everything is concentrated in a way
where the recipe is there for really
extreme suffering we're seeing that by
some estimates i think two million homes
roughly damaged or destroyed
prop systems you know extremely affected
um 33 million people uh by one estimate
you know experiencing so here we have a
case where pakistan is not one of the
big carbon footprint
emitters of the world yet they're
suffering badly
from the inaction
of other nations that are
and that's that's tragic
it's tragic and it's not fair right just
as it's not fair that uh young people
who haven't been responsible for for
emissions are going to be the ones who
who suffer the most inherit the mess
yeah yeah but you know hey here on the
upside guess what we're going to suffer
too so oh that's the upside thank you
chuck for that
thank you yeah i mean you know so so in
a flood what what is what is the primary
cause of death is it fast-moving waters
or is it
it's the standing water that becomes
uh
germ-infested yeah disease disease and
waterborne illnesses yeah what is the
more typical way of flood causes flood
deaths
yeah i don't i'm not sure the answer to
that question my first thought it's
probably the depth of the water and how
quickly the water is moving that tends
to be the most important certainly in
the short term but i think it's an open
question that you're raising which is
are we accurately counting the long-term
damages whether it's mold in a building
right whether it's groundwater pollution
um you know as as chemical sites or
you know right you have sewage backing
up because now there's a liquid liquid
pathway between your sewage treatment
your
your sewers and your roads and homes
that's right and thinking about this now
i'm thinking now about the pakistan
example that damage to these crops right
what's that going to mean in a country
where there's a lot of people who are
food insecure
mental health issues of flooding and you
know losing your home and your and your
livelihood so it may actually really be
an open question of of which aspect of
the flooding
is the most detrimental so are there
parts of the world that are particularly
at risk that you can warn the world
about or do you they just kind of show
up and so it's kind of
not to sort of
uh
make this a contest but if you
after the fact say see i told you so
well
did you really did you say pakistan was
at risk no you said the world is at risk
and then it shows up in pakistan do do
your models allow you some precision of
time and place that was weren't
available previously to planners yet
climate models are improving i would say
you know the climate models help us do
these long-term predictions what are the
statistics of heat waves and temperature
going that's just not helpful if i want
to plan for tomorrow's flood and i don't
know it's going to flood tomorrow yeah
so we have weather models too which are
you know what are used to forecast
what's going to happen to a hurricane
for example next week those certainly
are improved but just to distinguish you
have climate which is long-term averages
and you have weather which is what's
happening in your weather forecast right
yes yeah and those those forecasting
models have improved just a
general statement you hear sometimes is
that weather forecasting of today
is as successful looking at about five
days as weather forecasting was a
generation ago when looking out three
days right or even one day no i remember
you didn't know if it was going to rain
tomorrow you had to
your picnic would be on hold until
you know that morning and unless unless
your grandfather's bursitis was acting
though
rheumatism
on the porch
you got to be on the porch
we're in for a big one i'm letting you
know
chuck one day i want to meet all your
relatives okay
sorry bradley what about the bursitis
predictive forces
do you have an old man on your porch
that's a question i've never gotten
before i'm stumped yeah
right so just tell me let's get back to
what i asked um are you do you have what
kind of precision do you have about
certain regions that are highest at risk
yeah so yeah for in the sort of time
scale of the weather forecasting you
know we're getting better at this one
thing you're hearing more and more about
now is these atmospheric river events
these plumes of moisture sometimes
referred to as the pineapple express
because they often originate
generally speaking near hawaii right
with all it's with all its pineapples
under the right conditions you will get
a narrow ribbon
in the atmosphere of moisture
essentially a river
that can flow right into land and then
sometimes if the topography is right
topography is a huge part of flooding
start to rise up say this sierra
mountains in california dumping out all
their moisture rapidly we're seeing
instances now where some of these events
can be predicted a week or so
in advance roughly that's definitely
progress longer term you know how good
is how strong is the monsoon season
gonna be for pakistan next year a year
or two from now
we're making progress but there's still
a lot of uncertainty and i think a lot
of surprises a lot of areas have to
assume that things that they didn't plan
for could happen it would just be
helpful with all the naysayers if you
could say you know in the next two years
this region's going to have a
catastrophic flood and then it does
right yeah and then they'll shut up
finally and listen to you guys but one
one thing you can say
without in without any reservation is
that uh we have seen an intensification
of all
weather events
due to climate change and the climate
crisis and with that in mind if you look
at the worst thing that has happened to
you historically
you can count on that happening again
and or something worse or something much
worse yes is that a fair statement
that's what you should be that's what
you should be um preparing for
that is a fair statement and any time we
go beyond one city or one season
we have more statistical power so if we
start talking about a nation as a whole
the world as a whole or an average over
five or ten years here the statistics
are totally compelling right we're
clearly seeing those heavier rain events
more extreme heat waves fewer cold air
outbreaks and more drought right and
some people do need to plant at those
scales right your insurers your
reinsurers your emergency management
officials
they need they should be need to be
looking at that whole picture as they
balance their their resources and
geopolitically you could have climate
refugees when they're what some nations
in the
in the south pacific where this
the average is was a meter above sea
level or something or less
and
yeah no right we've been focusing on the
the sort of flooding that's coming from
rain events but let's keep in mind too
as sea levels rise as you know
coastal flooding right these these
storms that are piling water up through
their winds along the coast are going to
cause that water to go much further
inland than it did in the past even if
the storms don't get any stronger and
the winds don't get any stronger just
because the bathtub is higher right sea
levels higher right
and for places like you know where where
we're sitting in new york during a
certain storm it might be the blend of
all three higher sea levels
a stronger storm pushing more water on
the coast and heavier rain events yeah
exactly that was uh that was uh the
remnants they call it the remnant of
hurricane ida
so without the wind
we had a larger storm surge
than a hurricane
the most rainfall that ever happened in
the shortest period of time which
resulted in greater flooding that was in
manhattan right that was in manhattan
right right side of the suburban city
here right right
so it's this idea of like the compound
risks the multiple risks a lot of city
planners have said
how strong might the storm be how high
might the sea level rise be how much
rain might we get you got to put it all
together how are the risks of of all
these things occurring what's what phase
of the moon does does it have does it
hit your shores right yeah that's right
yeah
man what phase and what time of day it's
crazy that's great well one thing that
you said bradley that uh everybody
should take into account
uh which is insurance companies if you
want to
realize how real this problem is there
is not one insurance company
on earth that does not have
climate crisis contingencies and uh
prediction predictive models in their
business plan going forward for the next
50 years they in the military are the
leading major agencies that are not
climate deniers in this that's right in
this equation
and of course radley
[Laughter]
yeah but you know bradley's getting all
that sweet sweet government money oh
that's why he's doing it yeah you know
they're making it rain on him so he's
got to say this is going to happen yeah
of course of course a big science
conspiracy we all get together
that's right right
it's crazy guys we got to end our our
explainer here but this is fascinating
radley uh this is it's it's not every
day we just get a behind the scenes on
what's going on not only in the world
but in the models that predict it so
think we'd love to get you back on and
because we'll we'll find other excuses
to do this again because this is not
your only bit of expertise you can share
with us
with your permission we'll keep you on
the rolodex and young ends look up
rolodex google it you'll know what a
rolodex is
bradley uh how do we find you on social
media
um i'm on twitter uh at radley horton
radley horton okay we'll find you there
chuck your chuck nice comic as always
everywhere thank you yes telling people
your comic because they didn't otherwise
know is that by you well you know what
can i say i i like to reinforce what
people make
okay
you repeat it enough they'll believe it
right is that what it is
[Laughter]
neil degrasse tyson has been another
star talk explainer this one on flux
as always keep looking up
[Music]